so hello everyone uh and welcome to this
session of
intelligent soft matter so what we try
to organize is a workshop uh on very
unusual workshop and this and the
structure of this Workshop is also very
topic is unusual and the structure is
unusual uh so this is the website what
you see on this screen and uh this is
about intelligence of matter and it is
not uh it is emerging field so it is not
yet well developed and it will be maybe
in future one of the direction of the
soft matter and since not much it was
done in this field what we are planning
in this field and what we see what can
be done from different perspectives so
we have people working with uh materials
and soft matter and experimental right
and we have people from sensors and
nanop particles and how to to um to
sense the environment and we have also
people from decision making artificial
intelligence uh which also a different
field so there is a mixture of different
profiles and uh today what we wanted to
do because the topic is very unusual and
new uh here where is um uh a description
and uh and also we have a program and
all and we have also profiles of the
people so today what we wanted to do is
uh is to in this meeting should be uh
also an unusual format it will have an
unusual formats that it is not only
presentation of the of the talks but
also uh collaboration and initiation of
the collaboration and
discussion and uh uh we can and to to
initiate the this discussion and to make
it meaningful uh what we did is uh to we
we wanted to analyze the contributions
and also that people who will join that
they may uh know each other uh before
the meeting and also to have some ideas
of other people and also of other
directions and also other ideas of
people what they can uh bring to this
meeting and with whom they can meet and
what they already if we start writing a
paper for example we have in the plan uh
the paper
on though in those sessions we have a a
plan to write a perspective paper and
when we write this perspective paper uh
we should already prepare I and to to be
prepared and to prepare some some uh
part of this text and uh to be ready to
collaborate with people because still we
have very short time during the meeting
that's why uh I suggest so we have this
session and additionally we have a
session on grant writing session and
this is uh uh Pro will be um organized
by I leag uh and also with u uh this
will be a session traditional grant
writing and addition and and last day we
will have idea generation session which
is more open and it will be uh uh
prepared which is what we are doing now
we will will be prepared in
collaboration with uh two guests one is
uh Danielle uh fredman from California
and he is a director of the active
influence Institute and today we have
another guest is the Tobias K from
Netherlands and he is um uh a s of the
component knowledge pixels who is behind
of Nano Publications so why this is uh
important so we have uh uh we
have the uh in here what we we want to
do is to generate some ideas before for
the meeting this is the the the goal and
one side we will use artificial
intelligence and uh the modern tools
which allowed not only to present your
directions but also to get insights from
uh other fields through this automatic
process and this is this idea generation
process through field shift and this
will be presented by Daniel fredman and
on other side if we have those ideas we
can uh register those ideas as small
pieces of information with a name and
the and this can be a nanop publication
which can be in a uh machine readable
format and that can also allowed to
build on top of this piece of knowledge
so the then what we to see how we can
merge all those new technologies and to
see how it it is possible so first of
all I would like maybe to uh that maybe
our guests will tell a little bit about
themsel and also about this tools so
first of all we start with Tobias and
then with Daniel will leave maybe like
this so Tobias do you want to to present
your
Tool uh sure yeah
so um well I can just very quickly uh
introduce myself I'm Tobias Kon I'm
actually no longer based in the
Netherlands I'm still affiliated with
University there but I'm now in Zurich
Switzerland and have now we have now our
small startup called knowledge pixels
and um yeah as um Vladimir already said
we are um focusing on this concept the
technology of nanop
Publications um yeah I know do you want
me to now already give a give maybe one
or two minute that's a concept of this
nanop publication and then we go further
because then we will discuss how to
include it and after this how to merge
it later but if you just uh tell what is
the concept how it works and that's will
be enough okay yes of course so as the
name says an publication is like a
publication but tiny um and on top of
that it's a publication it's not just
written in English or or any natural
language but it's uh um written in you
could say a logic language if you're a
bit familiar with semantic web or link
data Technologies it's written in the
rdf language which means uh it's made of
sentences where you have subject
predicate object and all the three of
them are globally unique
identifiers um so people around the
globe can say things and when they talk
about the same thing it will
automatically connect uh um yeah if I
may kind of um simplify it a bit um so
nanop Publications are kind of these
tiny Snippets of such statements in the
simplest case it's just a single such
sentence with something is related with
that thing to that thing like I know in
the in medicine it could be this this
Gene has this
this kind of effect on this disease
often it's more than one such triple as
they are called because often statements
are a bit more complex uh than just a
simple triple and that together so these
couple of
statements then consists the main
content of nanop publication uh which is
called the assertion but then it always
has some Provence to it meaning you can
state with another such triple where
this came from for example because you
had a study that delivered it or because
it was extracted from an existing paper
or data set or whatever and then it has
some metadata where you can say who
created it with which tool uh with a Tim
stamp with a license and these things uh
and all that together then is an anop
publication it gets a stable persistent
identifier of its own and the the thing
that we are now working with the thing
that we providing is that you're
building a decentralized ecosystem
system for dealing with such nanop
Publications so you can push them to the
world basically to the nanop publication
Network and it can then live at
different places so when you later uh
you or somebody else want to retrieve it
again you can and because has this
formal structure you can also uh ask
very specific queries that can then
precisely be answered uh for humans to
consume but also for machines and for
applications to build up on um so we can
also on the flight create new classes
and ation so we can create new
vocabulary and then talk about it and
make n Publications you have a tool for
that that's called Nano Dash that is
supposed to be user friendly so it's
still kind of Cutting Edge so we there's
still a lot of work ahead of us um but
anyway so it's kind of a low threshold
to publish these and then you and others
can query it again and um yeah we're now
in the first steps to kind of apply this
more broadly um um across different
domains and with connections to journal
and yeah there's lot I could talk about
more but I think I've already used up my
three minutes yeah so that's exactly the
purpose of this uh uh tool how to use
this tool so it is machine readable
format and this is very short and easy
to publish and this goes in the
direction of the the new new trends of
this
uh language models then they come and
the the process of
Publications uh the dissertation right
writing projects writing and those
public Large review writing that becomes
Obsolete and already doesn't have much
sense to to have all this uh uh all all
this traditional Legacy publishing
system so instead of this it it goes in
the direction of very uh specific and
personalized uh tools and also so in the
artificial intelligence now becomes more
and more in the it goes in the more and
more in the direction of uh agent based
so instead of General tools for
everything so they have you will have a
a agent which will be uh doing some uh
work or task very personalized for you
and for for other people so you will
communicate through the agent and this
is how we see how this Publications can
enter into this domain and this is how
we connect with Daniel from active
influence Institute because the whole
Institute is focusing on the development
of
those artificial intelligent tools for
that will be uh making those agents
which will be making interaction between
humans and machine and this is one of
the examples how we can apply these two
uh uh intelligence uh soft matter to
this workshop and we can just show how
at this again this is a very early stage
but how this can be approached maybe now
Daniel you can come up and show this
tool and explain any about works
great I'm going to share my screen
okay
okay all
right
well thank you Vladimir for inviting me
and it's been really fun to collaborate
on these uh directions also Tobias
that's very exciting about the Nano pubs
I think broadly uh this is going to be
the unstructured
text getting into where the structured
information of Nano pubs is going to
supercharge it but e even today I think
there's some pretty fun and exciting at
least provocative directions to explore
um it's I'm going to push this all to
the GitHub link that's in the video
description and in the side
chat um okay so to kind of back up and
then we'll look at this on the open
source GitHub last week we had an
applied active inference Symposium at
The Institute and then
in uh those sessions we kind of
analogously had participant information
presenter abstracts and so on so working
with Vladimir we had some discussions
and we built some tools around like what
can we do to add value and
context before the event how can we
start to think about templates and
transferable tools and practices across
different related or overlapping or even
totally separate open science and
participation initiatives so we made
this repo called Symposium so Vladimir
made a bunch of uh edits and and commits
to the this uh before last week and
recently including adding in some open
source language model methods what I'm
going to show is just a few more
researcher
side process accelerations perhaps using
perplexity that's available through the
browser at perplexity Ai and here is
using the the API so what I did here is
I took the perplexity folder that I had
applied to the in active inference
Symposium participants and then adapted
this in this folder called ISM
stream for intelligence soft matter so
that's where everything that we're going
to talk about today is in here so this
is it just as the folder named it just
meant different pieces for people to
pull out um and explore and then also
I'll note that this is all done in
cursor especially as there was all
already a folder of this working for a
different structure but analogous tasks
getting to this ISM stream content was
was like 10 to 20 total prompts and
cursor updates um okay so in the inputs
folder Vladimir provided the information
on the
participants and also there's a cat so
here's intelligence soft matter and then
there's speakers and participants and
they each have this open Alex and this
works so the works are some citations
and
bibliography and the topics are are
topics of the
person okay so the what the first uh
script does is it researches the
presenter so everything goes into the
outputs folder here's the
presenter uh folder so in ad Jason and a
markdown here are internet-based
researchs
all experimental research tooling so
it's it's hard to even estimate
sometimes it's totally accurate if it's
little information in a common name this
isn't going to be very useful if there's
a ton of information and and links
provided it's super useful so this this
outputs a summary on the presenters um
but I I kind of wanted to
explore the uh working with the
participant information more so that's
what most of the following scripts are
so the second script two and all these
are run with just P from the ism stream
folder just Python 3 and then the name
of the script so for the
participants started off with
also writing uh research report I don't
know if we can look up someone who's
here now to see see how accurate it is
but yeah yeah g is here and it looks
quite accurate okay so again sometimes
it's super accurate sometimes double
check okay so wrote this wrote This
research report then this is where field
shift comes into play so these are just
sort of playing around with different
combinatorics of of what is possible and
also this is just using all by all
folder iterating so it's not using a
database it's it's hardly agentic in the
sense that we could call any part of a
computer pipeline agentic like is a
database search a search agent I guess
if we do think about it that way then it
is but this is just using all by all
iterating on these folders which keeps
it plain text and and really available
also for nanop pubs and GitHub and all
this so what field shift does there's a
folder called domain so in this folder
called
domain this is copying a folder out from
a
previous um repo and live stream called
field shift that was based upon some
work by Mike L slap so what domain has
is it has these synthetic knowledge
files so they're just specific questions
examples factual statements within a
domain so just some of them are they're
just meant to load up the context and
just provide information on a synthetic
domain but you could imagine that could
be like a person's record or an
organization's record or a different
kind of document but here just being
used just to say these are just
statements and open questions and
problems and this happened this year all
those kinds of things for different
domains so what three field shift does
is it takes each each participant's
background and it it um will find I
didn't run this for every single
participant but but we'll just run in
cursor now
so this takes each participant's
background and then at basically uses
perplexity to J toose researcher
background and the synthetic domain and
then asks what could they learn from the
field and how could they contribute to
the field so this is Daniel craft and RX
and fur and then the way that again
there's more sophisticated ways to do
prompt um engineering but what's
Happening Here is it just sending to
perplexity here's the participant
analyze the bidirectional knowledge
exchange between name and participant
here's the profile of the participant
here's the knowledge domain just copy
paste um it each of these take like so
here let's just look at this one that
just was
made here's what this person could learn
from RX iner these are accurate parts of
of what they could learn from that field
how could they contribute to the
domain I don't know but that that's from
into so that's that's field shift and
then that just iterates over whichever
domains are in the domain folder so it's
like here's statements about William
Blake
um that's uh three so that's the the
um field shift okay then Vladimir
provided a folder of catechisms so
catechism can mean different things but
in the project management setting it's a
set of question and answers that are
aligned with project management being a
grant officer program manager these
kinds of questions that are important to
be addressing so took this
for shifted
catechisms here this was like one prompt
from three copied three and said okay
now with the catechism in at catechism
folder write a that structure for each
of these shifted fields
so now with the Daniel craft blockchain
bir directional relationship now it's
going to write a
catechism with that
structure so it'll it'll take a few
seconds um then just while this one's
processing um the other way to use a c
ISM here is for all pairwise
participants write a catechism that
would reflect a
complimentary
project using the karma Gap I don't know
what it is but that catechism format so
we'll we'll look at
okay here's
five so here's Daniel craft X dong and
then that is just saying okay now for
these two
participants there's other ways that you
could fill up the context window and
everything but just saying here's how
you write the
document here's here's what here's what
we're looking for with the document
Styles here's the template of the
catechism here's the participant
information here's their other proposals
that we know from them here's their own
here's their field shifted um to and
from and then make a collaborative
project
okay first let's look at the just the
field
shift
um blockchain I I don't know this person
but we'll see you know they they can
see to and from
blockchain and then just last piece is
the collaborative proposal
we'll look at it in in
GitHub yeah maybe I can also show uh the
results when we we were Shifting the
profiles of the people because they are
coming from different domains uh to the
uh context of the workshop it's
intelligence soft matter and what was
the outcome uh so the were it was done
uh with three steps first step is to
generate profile of the each person and
also the questions uh maybe if I I
switch to online now let I I will I will
show the outcome of this uh result yes
Danielle
yes uh
okay uh uh this is here so this is also
in in the same uh uh giup GitHub folder
so if you go here so there is the inputs
and inputs are basically they are taken
from uh this is intelligence oft matter
and participants speakers
and we have outcome is the the
publication taken from open Alex so
there is a publication uh directions
research directions uh topics and uh
also citations so it's it this is uh
provided in in this format so we have uh
this as a basis so we don't use any
other information and we can do it for
any researcher and after this uh the
question was uh after we we have threee
u s generate profile of the researcher
with respect to the field
of intelligence of matter then we have a
researcher methods we it can extract the
methods and also description of the
methods from each profile and
additionally we can do collaborative
projects and the projects depending on
the catechism what Daniel explained so
what for example we have European
projects they have a a certain structure
if we have
a a American project or some other
funding then it will be completely
different questions and different
structure and it will be a differ so the
catechism is here so this just a text
file and for example we if we have
European grants this is a certain
structure if we have and here we we have
just another one this is katein for
karma projects and this is just the
questions what need to be addressed and
this is a structure first is a vision
and scope project statement proposal
solution collaboration knowledge
integration plan yes so we use this to
construct projects uh with and also
connections between people so then and
how it works so we
have it is in this folder synthetic and
here this is the also generated so first
of all we have all merged research
profiles of all participants in this
file so this is a um a automatically
generated file and the same we have
automatically generated description of
the intelligence soft matter and the and
this is current understanding future
Direction and changes so this is done in
this format and this is what is known in
general so this is basically uh
generated contracts but H you can also
have a look so this is also may be
interesting to see if you agree or not
and this is basically general knowledge
available in the internet about this
this field and future Direction so this
is again uh it is a rapidly evolving
with several excited future directions
and those are seven directions uh what
basically we it is discussed in the
literature so it is not coming from
anywhere and uh uh uh and we have also
open questions this is for fundamental
science for computational science uh
material design applications ethicals
and emerging questions so there are the
questions and future Innovation so this
is again uh how to to because if we talk
in the workshop about intelligence of
matter we need to talk what do what do
we consider it and this is our actual
State maybe after the meeting it will be
completely Rewritten we have a new ideas
and they will be doing this and here is
the beauty of this method so we can be
based everything is based on agents and
then we can re regenerate all the
structure again this is not a problem
because uh it takes maybe 10 minutes
after this we go to participants and
then again we can pick up the
participant uh there is a uh first of
all so we have a a research profile so
the research profile that you already
saw uh there is the research focus of
the person then we
impact analysis so this High cations
focus on fundamental corness we have
research Evolution from where it started
and where this researcher goes and then
there is a ke contributions and also
future directions with respect to this
field intelligence soft matter so uh
where this profile can fit in in in this
uh structure what we proposed and this
and if we will if in ENT oft matter will
be redefined this is fine then this all
those profiles will be again regenerated
and then uh another one is a uh the
collaboration so we know this field we
know where this researcher come from and
then the question is uh what
collaboration what is the matching
contribution he may search and here what
we see that there are several
suggestions to whom he may collaborate
so it will be
complementary and uh so that this is a
totally uh automatic uh and there you
can also have a look and then and after
this uh it a third uh part so we have an
second one is uh the pro we have methods
so we can ex extract methods from also
from Publications and then uh analyzing
those publication we can see that there
is a list of methods with a description
with Monto simulations and then with the
description and uh the result outcomes
then we have also several models so this
is we see all those uh theoretical
models and uh we see also emerging
Trends how this field evolves and
limitations for example if you use
scaling models scaling Theory rization
group what will will be the
limitations and uh this is very useful
when we talk about collaboration and
projects after this uh we go to Project
generation and for example this is the
project generated for this particular
researcher and here what we see is the
emerging computation and con biohybrid
materials networks so here we see all
description so then then
uh starting from the title uh they have
project rational and objectives so this
we have according to this catm uh what
we set up for example if we want to
structure it in the in the form of
European project there is a special uh
setup for European project if it is in
this was done for karma Gap and here we
see uh the um uh the structure for this
particular project and here what we see
all those topics like alignment with you
you calls project Vision objectives and
contribution to PO priorities expected
kpis then they have St of of the art
gaps and limitations
novelty um and then we we see also
alignment with Europeans this is uh by
the way this is a European structure
method methodology what can be done in
this methodology expected impact and you
added value and the long-term risk
management and this all this resources
and work plan and deliverables so this
is already uh we have this dissemination
exploitation so ethics and all these
things so this is a European structure
so we we have another
project uh which was
done uh here so this is another project
is a which which is called a different
type of project with a completely
different structure and this is
simplified this is karma Gap projects
are simplified and here we have a vision
and scope we don't have any Europe
Dimension gender balance and all this
things which will be uh
very particularity of the European
project here it is a vision and scope
why this project needed now a societal
need problem statement and uh proposed
solution and K Innovation and what is
also important that here we also see uh
with this project which is another type
of project with neuromorph soft met by
inspired mive Network ofed nanop
particles it just suggests the person
from the
workshop who will be the best contact
with respect to this uh uh project for
example here what is this idea so we
have a neuromorphic integration so this
is what is this so this is M resistors
and how to make them from soft matter
materials using photocatalytic nanop
particles embedded in polymer Matrix so
this is the topic and uh uh it was
generated so we have a connection with
other participant and uh we have a
structure already already for the grand
proposal and it was generated in 100
seconds so it's basically two 2 minutes
and you have a project like this then
with a full details and here also what
is also included uh Network and
collaboration so who else from the
meeting can contribute to this idea and
here because we know all the profiles so
they just list those people from the
from the workshop uh and how these
people can contribute to this particular
project and uh again we have this uh uh
methods so this is again what methods
need to be taken into account they have
this St
Sam spectroscopy so computational data
biological data machine learning so then
it will be uh also the structure of the
implementation plan so this is structure
of the project we it can
be a several year project and how to
structure it and uh we have a
methodology what what else is necessary
and what is missing and you see a the it
says also that not all people from the
workshop is enough that we will be again
uh some extra people this uh material
scientist engineer it's missing and we
don't have it in the workshop but if we
just limit people from the workshop it
just give you this uh those names which
are more suitable for this project so
this is uh the the the way to operate so
this is this will be just an example of
course we can delete this all and it may
not uh maybe not
uh it will be just an example so this we
can use it as an example of future
collaboration so for us it is important
that if you can just log in and have a
look of researcher profiles it is also
possible to generate for uh even for
each person to whom to talk and to to
which subject for example you can with
your profile then you can talk to
another person and also present
something that maybe you don't even
realize that you can work together on
something on this and that's maybe we
can have a list of people and to topics
that you can address those people
because they are experts in this
field so this is more or less what we
are doing now and this is how the the
this uh field is developing so and I I
know that Daniel want to show something
else thank you Vladimir that's
awesome that's cool okay I'm going to
show the last piece of the script and I
mean I hope this is giving some fun ways
in each symposia that you all or anyone
organizes or or we organize we can keep
on iterating and making it more
interesting okay let me just
share take a second
[Music]
do you
see okay let me try screen sharing
again I'll just show this for um a
minute than than any any thoughts
or questions on
this okay H says I can't share my
screen I'll try one more
time Roger
Sherin
[Music]
okay so meanwhile if you have any
questions you can
ask let me just reload I'll be back in
one second
interaction and and this is why we we
also see a big uh
um very
big potential in nanop Publications
because uh this is the way to structure
the pieces of information which is uh
relevant and which you can say this
because if you build a project what you
everything can be generated but what is
important is what is really uh
verifiable uh data and what is a
statement which is
a is a you can trust and this is where
this nanop publication come because you
don't need the whole paper you don't
need to write to read reviews but what
you need is to to have those pieces that
you can construct your own project you
can construct your own paper or
something like this and this is uh can
be also
done
automatically yes and this is where we
see this interaction between AI humans
and the this system of the blockchain
which is basically uh what the to
shows okay um it's it's uh it's a funny
thing but just navigate over to the is M
stream and I'll show I'll show it on the
stream but just for those in the in the
chat um in the ism stream there's a
stream there's a folder six called
visualize um and what what visualize
does again it'll be visible on the
uh
stream I'll run it in Koda
2 okay first thing it does is it
iterates over each kind of the output
document so the researcher profiles I I
know you don't see it in the Google chat
but but it's visible on the on the
stream but just it just a funny thing is
happening but then um it iterates over
each kind of document like the research
profiles and the other and then it uses
standard set of linguistic analysis
methods like like topic modeling and
principal component analysis all these
will be in the in the um visualizations
folder and and so it makes for example
principal component plots and and what
those principal components um are loaded
on for different researchers and looks
at different topic modeling and
statistical aspects of of the semantics
of the event so that opens up a lot of
really interesting possibilities for
like designing unlikely connections and
setting up projects that are in certain
regions and especially combined with the
methods that Vladimir just mentioned
Nano pubs I mean having a nano CV with
available methods this is really
changing the game because of the
semantics being openly accessible and
the rate limiting step to a large extent
being like what projects are really
going to happen with who and
how uh yes I we see uh the ail first M
MH oh okay thanks thanks a lot for this
is I got the the general pictures very
clear and what I don't have clear is so
how can we refine the the results
because all these results were obtained
by automatic information that you know
we're in the web but uh how do you what
is the how do you iterate in such a way
that you know this can be refined
because this could be all junk right in
PR yeah yeah yeah of course yes and this
is the way that this is just to give an
idea of before the meeting for of other
participants and then to see what can be
done and then uh to uh refine it is
basically on the the field what you want
to to achieve then uh the structure of
of the questions what you need to to
answer and uh also the profile method
profile so this the basic information
then it because what it does is just the
shifting so example if you have a method
in in polymer physics so and you want to
apply it in some maybe some elements of
[Music]
quantum quantum theory into polymer
physics so and you know that this is how
Deen got to Nobel Prize and then and and
he just go from one field to another
field and bring uh the tools within so
this is the how it does so this is just
merging different approaches which is
already common in One Direction in one
field and applying to another field and
then uh the Fe this is done with the
prompts this is prompts and there are
maybe 20 prompts which to generate uh
one document but you see that um
adjusting it then you can uh uh improve
a lot and put more details it will put a
lot so this is the short answer there
it's in GitHub so get people to have
editor access on the repo for the event
and then have it just as a starting
point and make edits in collaborative
fashion and get just like anything other
else okay thanks thanks a
lot and
rudol yeah thank you very much for this
for this very interesting presentation I
think that could be sort of a game
changer I've I I I I will be very open I
do not yet really see how that act
actually works in practice but I I like
i' love to try it out man I'm a little
bit uh most of the questions have
already be answered because I had more
or less uh my questions headed into the
same directions as ailles uh but I
haven't got and that may be my fault I
apologize because I had to go to the
door briefly but how do we
operationalize this during our meeting
M right then we have to we have to
prepare something and we have to okay
and this is why I I prepared uh the coda
uh link so this is a link where you
already some people already joined uh
the join publication because we have um
publication so it is already assign
topics because they are writing what
they want to contribute and more
important that you come already with the
idea what other people are doing what is
their contribution and you can already
have ideas
of what do you want to write in and what
do you want to say about this field or
maybe this and then H is the way uh to
to to do it because then here it just
it's like a Google Document and then you
can modify it and whatever you want you
just put it there text and after this we
will discuss already this draft because
draft is there we have also the
definition of the field is also there
and it is coming from me it's it's may
be wrong so that's say but it can be
also uh then you can modify it and Al
also you can change this direction
because what we will also ask a question
what is the
minimal uh uh version of those a AI uh
all this uh intelligence in in the uh in
the materials on what are the limitation
of of experimental limitations so this
kind of things I invite you to join C if
necessary we can open more documents
there and then you can
contribute okay very good I do so no
thanks a lot yeah that's amazing man I
to me it sounds as an experiment and I
apologize man see I I'm an old guy so uh
learning new technologies is always hard
for me but let's try it will'll be
fun Vil
yes uh hello um I have a quick question
um these profiles that are automatically
generated for all us can we modify them
if we think that something is not yeah
of
course a text file you can modify it's
it will be better because if you modify
your profile that will be much better
because and and and and and we can and
and we can access them in the website
somewhere or yeah yeah yeah and it it
can be done like it's in a
open it can be um done with access yes
okay thank you yeah just to share like a
funny thing from the previous Symposium
a presenter with a name that was shared
with another researcher the perplexity
internet search on profile was 100%
incorrect so then this person looked at
it sent in an updated manually written
version but that's a shortterm type
thing as we're just experimenting on
these early iterations planning more
weeks and months out and then at a
deeper time scale having more updated
information and Clarity around what's
open and what's shared with organizers
and organizations and so on about who's
available for what and what's updated
information on their Nano Publications
and on their preferences on their
capacity the more and the more relevant
and accurate that information is enables
this kind of decentralized knowledge
collaboration using synthetic methods
better so wherever accurate information
can be shared it's like it'll be
leveraged if the information is not in
the research profile then it's not going
to come into play in the later catechism
based grant
yeah so uh we have
now few minutes before the the end and
yes
V just another quick one uh okay so what
is the best time
frame uh
until we can update our profiles so the
engine will have enough time
to uh Pro
until that's until the meeting we have
roughly 8 nine days know this this you
can modify this is this is just a a toy
model we'll see how it works and after
this we will see during the meeting
maybe for sure we will have much better
ideas that
now
okay yeah that sounds really exciting to
have months in advance clear streamlined
non overloading
Communications have accurate information
connect people and then enjoy the
possibilities for having connections at
events and symposia given that they're
only several hours long and use the
before and the during and the after to
to recognize and build on all of this
amazing work and people who are at
different career stages there's and so
many connections with how prior
publishing methods
existing grant opportunities new
publishing methods like nanop Pub new
grant
opportunities yeah this will will
explore a lot because European grants is
not the only option but now it is
becomes more and more the decentralized
funding that comes from um also from
this blockchain and uh decentralized
science is the same so you don't need or
even University to be researcher and
then you can collaborate through the
such tools and this is how also Daniel
operate this institute is a
multidisciplinary and distributed this
is uh the future I think
yes okay so if no more questions then uh
uh we meet each other very soon almost
in a week and uh we we will start with
with this discussion in in in life
yes okay thanks thanks a lot Vladimir
thank you thank you for your
time thank you very much thank you